good morning Millennials I dare anyone
to try and get a word in because
Taylor's trekker is here and the only
person who talks over other people more
than me is this [ __ ] hi girl I missed
you so much
you're suppose to be on the show like
two weeks ago but I cancelled because
I'm a flake but I'm glad you're here now
and obviously I waited till the last
minute to fill in for co-host so you you
got you out on board yesterday and I'm
so appreciative of your flexibility well
I love you I love you full disclosure
I'm a little under the weather this
[ __ ] only comes only shows up when
she's got like bronchitis or some [ __ ]
I'm always [ __ ] sick you are I've got
to look into that maybe you don't have a
high immune system or whatever I'm gonna
say that that's what it is for sure
maybe I'll stop drinking how are you
know you're fun drugs I know I haven't
drank in a whole week you haven't and
it's been glorious I drink two days ago
oh my god I'm jealous
why didn't why'd you take the week off
because I've been so sick I mean I'm
like I'm if I'm a human today but I was
like sweating yeah and like feverish
like gagging for days I feel like the
only thing that actually gets me to stop
drinking is like illness me too yeah now
that I think about it what then I swear
it off yeah of course I always wear it
off but so much part of like my life
involves drinking uh duh uh and I also
just want to have fun and I'm sorry
drinking is fun I know and we live in
New York City I know it's like you went
it's like I just went to an engagement
party I was so tired I'm like I'm gonna
stop in for one minute it was it wasn't
my direct friend it was my my best
friend at least yeah her brother so like
okay I'm like her I'm the little
sister's friend I'm gonna show up and
we're there for five minutes and then
we're out I want to be in bed obviously
was the last person at the party taking
shots like with the DJ like I don't know
why I just I want to have a good time
Carl I'm here for it and when I get near
a bar I'm like suddenly not tired
anymore well you know what happens to me
at Jackie's wedding right no I went
crazy you did by the way there was
something in the water like so many
people went crazy and like had to be
sent home that makes me feel so good
happen that's another reason why I'm not
drinking so much because my girlfriend
Taylor like made me hopeful back stop
let's say this I through Chanel on the
ground my own Chanel at the wedding at
the wedding we then take a left
actually she makes me feel so much
better because it's so of course in my
mind well ladies friends like literally
had to be carried out and put in a gap
oh thank Jesus
yeah so my only thing is poor Heather
McMahon one hundred tally Italian we're
at their table which was like I was so
excited I'm like right we're gonna bond
either so or not they're so fun I was
like hey you take him I cut to K leaving
me coming back and like doing the thing
where I'm like was I meet her oh my god
and they were like what anyway I texted
Heather and I was like if you never want
to speak to me again it's okay you
embarrassed yourself I was a slob kabob
now when you woke up the next morning
how did you feel because I think the
worst part about like making mistakes
when you're drunk it's not actually the
mistakes it's the way you feel the next
morning like the moral hangover so I
wake up the next morning and I had to do
my live show Caroline's [ __ ] so I had to
get on the apology train immediately
yeah the time cuz I couldn't do like a
fight with Tay all day long and then
like go to a live show no but then my
entire show was about that that's funny
actually right how were the live shows
they're good
Carolyn's is fun they got great food um
how are your life shows I mean I'm still
hung over from the party at Foxwoods
everybody Foxwoods know we need that
were like I go to AC a lot so I feel
like Fox Sports is a place I like should
be at more often because it's the same
distance just in a different direction
it was [ __ ] lit like I went to the
club afterwards and it was like legit as
hell like I felt like I was in Vegas
like not at all but in Connecticut in
Connecticut very lovely Indian
Reservation you know it was lovely I had
a great time but wait you're selling
these like insane theaters out yeah it's
absurd a rock star oh I mean like I
every time I come out stage like I'm a
monster like don't you know not want to
see me backstage cuz like now they're
like I'm in the theater I think that I'm
like [ __ ] like shar-pei I'm very like
critical of myself like whenever it can
be the greatest show like everyone comes
backstage and they're like that wasn't
me
like it was I just don't have a good
grip I'm like what I do well or not I'm
like in a theater you can't hear
anything on stage so it's like are
people laughing I don't know that's
actually true you really can't in a
comedy club you have a much better like
grasp on what's going on that you can
hear it's annoying it has both ends it's
like I could hear when someone farted
because a comedy club like there's an
echo and when people are talking around
their phones like I'm so acutely aware
of it but when they left I'm more aware
of it and it's instant gratification
whereas I can a theater I'm like this
bit just 300 feet away I don't know if
she's having a good time right you know
I can guarantee they are because when I
was at your Boston show everybody around
me was dying and I took my brother yeah
because he doesn't he's not like my
sister stands you I wanted my brother to
come cuz I wanted you like you know I'm
like cyan't be biased yeah that's a good
point and he was blown the [ __ ] away I
paid her to say that and to be here just
to hock tickets to my show I'll be in
Phoenix in LA he goes like this to me
that's your friend thanks dad how are
you sister your brother your fab has
everyone Sam's grades
sisters great and taser forgive you tase
finally forgiven me um she did leave me
home sick yesterday she was sick and
tired of my ass she was sick and tired
of me if you being sick and tired like
literally so she went out for Saint
Patrick's Day and I slept I know she's
Donohue that's like her that's our day
it's her holiday yeah so of course I
cried when she left
where did she like oh yeah where did she
go it should do I don't like st. Patty's
Day is like so far into me I'm like the
opposite of the person who she felt me
too what what did she do she met with
her sister and like drank and I was by
now I know she's so like you ever see
the movie silver linings playbook yeah
it's like they're all of the Eagles on
our Irish yeah that is Taylor
totally that's so funny I know well
Taylor is here to break down to fast
five stories that you need to know
before you wake up and take a bite out
of your morning toast okay me today and
you know the new cycle didn't stop this
weekend [ __ ] was lit and not in a good
way because former That's So Raven star
Kyle Massey sued for alleged sexual
misconduct with a minor now Kyle Massey
was a personal favorite character of
mine I love that so raven and more
importantly I loved his spin-off Cory in
the house hear hear the details former
Disney star Kyle Massey is being sued
for 1.5 million dollars for allegedly
quote attempting to commit
you'd act with a minor the suit was
filed anonymously and that's refers to
the accuser as Jane Doe who's allegedly
a minor and kept her name out of it due
to the highly sensitive and personal
nature of the subject matter her mother
and oh okay
filed on her behalf according to court
documents obtained by E news chain and
Anto alleged their relationship with
Nancy dates back to when Jane was four
years old you know
when they allegedly met at Universal
City according to the lawsuit the 27
year old actor allegedly maintained
contact with Ann and her family and
became a father figure to Jane the
daughter allegedly wanted to pursue a
career in entertainment so Massey
according to the lawsuit would offer to
use his success and influence in the
entertainment industry to help her out
Jane Doe allegedly reached out to Massey
when she was 13 and supposedly texted
him and said she would love to audition
for his show Cory in the house
the suit alleges that Massey offered to
fly Jane out and have her live with him
Massey alleged allegedly called Jane so
sweet and beautiful in a text to an I'll
take care of her he allegedly wrote oh
you know I mean like abducted in plain
sight vibes right I mean I didn't know
that you could like sue someone
anonymously I didn't really either what
do you think though when they don't
press criminal charges and just go like
right mom yeah I mean we're led to think
like it's shade vibe totally but like I
mean I watched did you watch them
leaving Neverland oh my shoe kiss and
there were so many instances where like
people sued him or pursued criminal
charges and in the cases where he
settled out of court it like kind of
took away from like the belief for
people like people like well they
obviously were just out for the money
because they didn't pursue criminal
charges and they just settled out of
court and then he couldn't speak on any
of it cuz like all the NDA's and [ __ ] so
I mean I believe what Michael Jackson
did to be true so I don't know 80s weird
I guess oh so so if he they were
pursuing criminal charges they couldn't
do it anonymously but there's statute of
limitations right so if they were over
that then they could only do like a
civil suits in that case right that's
process California I don't know what it
is and I don't know how long ago was the
statute of limitations like I think it's
trash it's [ __ ] it's [ __ ] looks
like I was a criminal 15 ish years ago
so we recount and like most people don't
just like do a crime and then like never
do one again you know yeah it's really
[ __ ] up
this is really sad because like honestly
growing up MSE wasn't like a role model
to me really I [ __ ] loved that so how
does that feel are you like going to be
done with any of the article of the
breadth of the work right look I am in
denial but like the thing is I was I was
about Michael
forever were you and then leaving
Neverland was like like it was
horrifying horrifying like really like
it's undeniable okay I mean I I mean it
should be undeniable but like just go
into Twitter and seeing what people are
saying it's like if you search the
hashtag Libby Neverland like it's
shocking how many people are denying it
I know and then it's like I know Twitter
is it necessarily like the best place to
like see what the real world thinks
because the people on Twitter or just
the people like with the loudest voices
not necessarily like the right people
and I think it's awful like the super
negative people or look more like the
like there than these rollers they're
like always looking at it's like they're
always looking to see the opposite you
know well thank God Cory in the house
isn't still on because like honestly
would make it very difficult for me not
to watch it well like I couldn't watch
the Bill Cosby Show again right I never
watched it but I mean I barely did you
outgrow up with it I mean kind of more
so Michael Jackson though like I can't
listen to his music anymore
yeah I wasn't a big Michael Jackson like
music fan but like honestly there are
some bops by r.kelly that I no longer
can participate in remix to ignition I
know and you know right when the
documentary came and I was at a party
and they played it like the dance floor
literally cleared really people are mad
yep and that's what did you watch the
series [ __ ] Billy yes so good it was
good and what they said was like he had
a career change like when people started
to come on to him and he would start
making more gospel music that like a lot
of people would play at like weddings
and bar mitzvahs partment sounds but
like weddings and like life events so
it's now like our Kelly has now
infiltrated people's lives because now
you have memories of like your wedding
or like you know a baptism or whatever
where you're playing are Kelly and it's
like he infiltrated those positive
memories because he changed his music to
be like wholesome family music yeah
which that's like even more corrupt my
nip you let him manipulate it I feel
like it's really disgusting like that
entertainment like all I watch now is
like documentaries about like people who
were like abused or got kidnapped right
what is that are we six
watching it it's like entertainment TV
is supposed to be like this escapism or
like you love like that's why I really
love housewives like it's so not in tune
with what's going on in the world like
no that's why I like even in Real
Housewives in New York last year when
they started talking about the election
I was like this is actually interesting
but please stop like the election took
over the entire world yep it was really
like difficult and I love turning on
housewives and they have no idea what's
going on in the world because they are
like this elite class of people who are
just not in tune with what's necessary
over like signage at a party between
write me every moaning yes so it's like
that was frustrating so I think it's
like it's really just cussing and I'm
not really into like as much
documentaries as most people are like I
don't want I don't want abducted in
plain sight the Horsehead Bundy thing
but I watched like the celebrity ones
obviously but it's like really
disgusting and you know who I blame
Stassi do you blame Stassi I do man a
culture of like being obsessed with like
murder and ghosts what is that I mean he
next Lane she actually may say thank you
for that compliment every time could you
come on my show I like to make you speak
on stuff yes perhaps because Stassi like
won't come on but she really should come
on is she just like a she would have so
much fun you know she's just honestly
she's killing it with her book oh my god
so we pre-ordered it
Sam's pre-order now I actually was I
stayed with her so I stayed it tossed
and then I stayed with her when I was
out in LA last week and we were supposed
to do a podcast and she was like yeah
don't you [ __ ] tired she's just tired
at episode where she met Bo's mom I'm
behind
okay so kinda so so they went to lunch
or whatever and Bo like left to go to
the bathroom and he left his phone there
and recorded what happened and then they
had him listening to it for the first
time in his confessionals like on those
sidebar oh my god and saucy was
basically just like I love Bo so much
like thank you so much for like letting
me have him and like he's such a great
guy and like Bo's face when he like
heard Stassi like I actually wanted to
die I'm gonna cry no it was so precious
and it's just like really interesting to
see the arc of her relationships on the
show right it's actually they look so
relatable like when you're in your
twenties and you just like date [ __ ]
like you don't know yourself worth yeah
and they like you meet someone who
changes that I just like I love that you
know I was like Connor
I wasn't responsible for Patrick no but
you were very much in actually no you
were 100% responsible you knew Patrick
from work sorry I tried to circumvent
that but like you were well I
interviewed her that's how I met her and
then she tweeted Patrick from listening
to him and then he texted me and said
this crazy hot girl from reality shows
so responsible is tweeting me should I
text her I said do it no I mean you
didn't know and on paper he really was
like so cute does he know cuz I got
Erika hates him I really don't know we
really haven't spoken in a very long
time totally hates you because like you
put him in that position and now
everyone [ __ ] hates him because he's
she could one side you got him on that
show essentially and like the whole
world just torn apart for being a
complete but you know what I'm sure in
his mind that's the way it went that's
somewhat like an egotist would think oh
man he looks really bad on that season
it was it was that what he was like in
real part like sometimes people like a
reality show just like catches you in a
bad time or like it makes you really
like self-conscious so it's not always
an accurate representation of people
like you were on summer house for five
seconds and did you think that was an
accurate representation when you throw a
drink at someone yes
okay but do you think that's actually is
that what patrick was actually like I
like to say this Patrick when you're you
you were seeing Patrick at his absolute
worst and that's what he looks like when
he's at his absolute works like was he
could like back up against the wall
pissed off doesn't want to be there or
not like doesn't want to play he didn't
want to film he didn't want to film he I
remember watching thinking I wish he
just said now yeah but it was like a
point of contention in the group that
Stassi like had this part of her life
that she wouldn't share when they all
really like bleed out for the show and
make it as good as possible
and that's what I think everyone's
problem is machinae it's like you have
like you don't even hang out with us in
real life like you you put on a show for
the actual show where it's like this is
our real life like Carson and Kristen
but they're going through a not like
that's legit as [ __ ]
no kidding yeah Kristen kept me up till
5:00 in the morning talking about it
with me at stassi's birthday
so when was Thompson's birthday that was
in June so on watched up inside like two
weeks ago and asked for you and Carson
still together and she was like honestly
I bleed out for the show and like we're
just like taking some time off right now
and I don't want to talk about it well
when I was just out there
she was over at stassi's and he wasn't
there yeah I mean it got really really
talked about it right it got very real
when they started saying that like he
basically just like Mitch's off of her
and like pays she pays his friends I
think that is like the most disgusting
thing a guy can do me too is that like
so unfair though because I feel like
it's a double standard and you know
we're always doing time I could maybe
like get it girl are you a girl you make
him pay your players I'm like Lala
when Lala's out of my guest [ __ ] get
that Range Rover pj like when it's the
other way around I totally agree but
there's something about it that's just a
key
it is a key and I guess it's like he's
also like rude to her which makes it so
much worse whereas like Lala like
respects the [ __ ] out of Randolph have
you marry or ships him never met Randall
have you met Lala Matt Lala love her
love I'm your man made out with my
friend I love her I am here for um I
mean what did she say her kitty cat what
do you mean her kitty cat takes that do
you good oh she says the crate she won
me over in that moment she says the
craziest effect the most insightful like
weirdly feminist things you know but in
a pornographic way and it's like if
Gloria Steinem met la la I can't she
would be like you are not a feminist but
I actually think that like Lala Kent is
weirdly like the progressive postmodern
feminist of our generation okay great
like she's so embraces who she is in the
most like honourable way like I really
feel like I'm the most competent person
and like I don't give a [ __ ] what anyone
says but like when I meet Lola and I'm
like you know I love her and I love her
we go from talking about Kyle Massey to
Stassi but all those we back to Stassi
okay let's jump back in to our second
story well we wish everyone the best in
the Kyle Massey drama now this is a
great jumping-off point from the Michael
Jackson of it all perish Jackson is all
smiles with boyfriend after medical
scare so something really weird happened
over the weekend where TMZ reported that
Paris Jackson had attempted to commit
suicide and she was apparently in the
hospital or whatever and like thirty
minutes after that happened the weirdest
thing happened
Paris Jackson replied to Bethenny
Frankel's tweet where Bethenny Frankel
was like just talking about it and
Bethenny Frankel ends up deleting her
tweet but she was like it's lies it's
lies it's lies and then she responded to
the TMZ tweet article saying that she
committed suicide be like shut the [ __ ]
up you [ __ ] [ __ ] liars
then like an hour later she was like
convenient
paparazzi with her boyfriend whereas
like she hasn't been paparazzi in years
it's all very weird so Paris Jackson
stepped out with a smile on her
boyfriend after being treated for a
medical scare that's what they're saying
now ok-hee news had learned on Saturday
that the twenty-year-old model and
daughter of the Michael Jackson of the
late Michael Jackson had an incident
that morning that required medical
treatment and that she was resting at
home and doing fine
he news also learned that TMZ had a
report stating that emergency responders
placed her under 5150 hold at a local
hospital for a few hours that was untrue
Paris later posted on Instagram story a
selfie in a vehicle writing [ __ ] you I'm
chillin like Bob Dylan on Saturday Paris
was photographed driving and walking in
LA with her boyfriend Sam flowers
bandmate Gabriel glad and she was all
smiles during the outing so I don't know
I mean when I heard that she had
committed suicide before was anything
I'm like I mean I was like that's so sad
I wasn't necessarily shocked because
she's always struggled with depression
and now like the whole world it's like
talking about her dad and like it's just
sad and it's so not her fault and like
I'm like damn this is this sucks but
then now I'm just confused and I'm
honestly now I'm like becoming
suspicious do you know what I mean yes
it just looks weird so you think she
actually did try to commit suicide no I
don't know I mean she's yeah I don't
think you could just walk around out and
about like the next day I mean if you're
Paris Jackson you could write it's just
the lawyers world that we live in has
made me like so crazy suspicious of
everyone I know and also I don't even
know if I believe any story like doesn't
have the celebrities hand in it in some
way shape or form totally so maybe it's
like a sympathy ploy totally and maybe
the [ __ ] you was like a denial even
though she planted the story right no I
mean just when I heard it I was like
damn it's almost I like when Bobbi
Kristina was like really going through a
very hard time yeah and then this story
broke that she also was in the tub I was
like oh my god that's so sad but I
wasn't necessarily shocked by it no this
was like the same thing I like felt
really badly but I was like I almost
like felt it coming and I feel like she
doesn't have like a strong support
system around her do you mean not at all
I also I read a story that said that her
and her brothers have not seen the
documentary oh really
has she not I don't know I mean I don't
would you like
absolutely not right where's blanket I
don't know that where are the other kids
like
how many are there there's three yes oh
it's Faris Prince and blanket I went on
one of their instagrams I might have
been Prince because I would remember
seeing the name blanket on Instagram and
he'd like had it's a very normal life
really yeah like Paris really wanted to
be like celebrity spawn Calvin Klein
glamour a you know glamour icon woman
award right she wanted that and then I
don't know if she could never get back
to that just cuz like all the world is
talking about now I was like the
horrible disgusting vile things her dad
did do you think that shirt entire like
life and career will go down because of
what her dad did um and is that fair
right I don't know I mean I I don't
think that it will do you think she was
abused by him oh my god I didn't even
think of that
that's the other thing you know I think
that the girls were safe oh right that's
true that is very true I like what about
blankets and what about blanket yeah
it's looking at a girl or boy
blanket is a boy I believe okay remember
what do you put blanket over about Cook
balcony with the blanket that's the
thing about the Michael Jackson scenario
it's like everyone's like so shocked by
it but there was like a lot of telltale
signs that something was amiss like a
running around getting paparazzi and in
hotel rooms on tour with kids to having
kids being such a important like part of
your tour where like your music is
rather provocative and so are your dance
moves like right now junk like it we
just not it's like a kin friendly
environment but there was so much about
it that was like a focus on kids 3 you
literally bought a house and opened up
an amusement park in your house for kids
weird for you dangled your baby over a
balcony on a hotel terrace like lots of
weird things that I feel like maybe the
world should have like been paying
attention to yeah but maybe that's just
me now I am with you but I was such a
fan that I was like Michael really just
you didn't tribute it to him being like
this I I convinced myself he was asexual
I convinced myself that he was a child
what he convinced everybody else up I
did as myself of I was like he's a child
at heart so even though it's
inappropriate to have slumber parties
with kids he was robbed in childhood
thinks he's 10 so he's doing something
normal
were you I was wrong in denial until the
documentary or something yep really like
literally that far wait that's so crazy
it's like I feel like one of those crazy
r.kelly people yeah
uh-huh I mean and they still exist
they're showing up at court and like you
know the person he couldn't afford his
bail he was okay some some de Caro Nair
owner
yeah because day care owners have so
much money and so much kids like what
the [ __ ] it's like so morally corrupt
the morally corrupt Faye Resnick I feel
like there are so many phrases I use in
everyday life that I learned from
housewives like the word pernicious I
only know because of Camille Grammer and
I don't say I don't even know what it
means
perfect I don't I do like like the house
I was like defines my life like I sat on
my home like after their like design
like [ __ ] Kyle Richards house is so
nice wait do we think that Kyle Richards
and Mauricio have like the best marriage
yeah I mean and they tried to throw a
wrench in it remember when Lisa
Vanderpump convinced Brandi to bring
those magazines to Mexico yes about a
bat Mauricio like having an affair yes
with a crossdresser or something like so
like not real Oh far fast yeah and it
turned out and obviously not to be
churned they just have like a berry you
know what it is they have like a really
like obviously they have the love but
they have like a mutual respect for one
another and each other's work like
Maurice you take the house sighs [ __ ]
seriously he's gonna show up to film
with his agency hat on and push the
brand on everyone do you think that his
agency yeah where it is today because
the housewives yeah and they know that
too and that's why Kyle takes her job
very seriously as a housewife and that's
why she's created this alliance with
Lisa Vanderpump that is slowly crumbling
slowly crumbling and like when she
talked about her house getting robbed
like I feel so bad but / like I wish I
robbed her house no Sam I mean she had
amazing style furniture and like now
when she opened up her house for that
barbecue I like wanted to buy everything
in her house and you know who designed
her house it's Faye Resnick the more
like the morally corrupt no matter how
many Chanel bags you borrow you will
never be a lady not true I loved it I
literally went shopping after I saw her
house and I'm like I want that out a
minute I went onto article and I was
like I want that ottoman I'll take that
chair dining room please and I couldn't
afford any of it and [ __ ] is expensive
but I bought on article which has been
so premium for a million reasons one the
delivery guy was so nice really he gave
me he's like I'm gonna be there in an
hour is that okay I was like who the
[ __ ] is this
he said it's your article delivery I was
like okay and then it just showed up in
my house like I mean it was all just
like put together it was really a pretty
experience that's a nice experience yes
so article is offering our listeners $50
off their first purchase of $100 or more
to claim visit article dot-com / toast
and the discount will be automatically
applied at checkout
that's article dot-com / toast to get
$50 off your first purchase of $100 or
more no matter how many items every
order is shipped at a flat rate of $50
and it's just like premium ass I got
like this fluffy ass ottoman that like
when we film with my Home Tour Jackie
was like damn where's that from but I'm
like it's article ooh when Jackie
compliment you on something like you
know it's right you know it's good like
homegirl just doesn't like shell out you
know she like that
but speaking of housewife that's a great
segue into our third story on your show
do you struggle it's like segue I find
that waiting to be like the hardest
thing whenever I segue I go with this
segue ya know it which means it's hard
to say like I'm gonna segue now like you
just don't let people know what you're
doing it's really hard because you're
proud of yourself
yeah that you found [ __ ] still look I
just said wait from housewives into
entertainment tonight says that Lisa
Vanderpump's appearance on the Real
Housewives of Beverly Hills reunion will
be quote a game-time decision their
source says so I don't know how legit it
is but when are they filming soon I have
to assume she after a rollercoaster
season on Real Housewives of Beverly
Hills Lisa Vanderpump isn't sure if
she's ready for the reunion special a
source tells Entertainment Tonight that
the reality star quote hasn't made a
decision on if she'll show up for the
reunion or not it's a very hard season
for her and a lot of friendships have
shifted however the cast didn't think
she'd show for the premiere party and
she did oh she did but she did get
photographed because I didn't see that
all the ladies posed together except for
Lisa huh that's weird so yes even show
well they do say that I did well you
even there right right
the reality star admitted to e t--'s
Bryce sander in February that she
initially asked Bravo and Housewives
executive producer Andy Cohen for a year
off the long-running series after the
death of her brother before ultimately
filming the show's night sees okay
that's fair and he said you know I think
we should have given you a year off when
you asked for it he said I don't think
you were in a mental state and when you
were really prepared to deal with it it
was a very emotional with hindsight we
probably should have given you the year
off that wasn't English I wasn't as
prepared for combat as I should have
been she confessed the drama in hospice
of Beverly Hills Season nine has
centered around a rift between bi
department co-star tarik Kemsley so I
want to get your hot takes on Vanderpump
rules but here's the thing if Louise I'm
in a room wanted to take a year off she
could have right she was not supposed to
return as the season before last and
they give her a million dollars to start
just for the season so she's not a
season by season
and if she knew she wasn't in the right
state it was it could have been her
decision and and do you like taking the
blame for it I don't think it's right I
think it's really kind and generous
Vandy I think that Lisa is a control
freak because I'm like what I know and
understand I think she's a lot of good
sides but I think that she's like I
think that she kind of is this like
chess-playing manipulator no being
friends with her is like playing chess
with Bobby Fischer yes I agree with that
that was Kyle Richards right and so I
think that she doesn't want to leave one
here cuz everything you go right yeah I
mean everything did go around she's
still here she just got way too
comfortable so tell me in the dog gate
okay my intent in so far behind okay
fine so I won't make you fill me in and
I can die and I can so you know to recut
this dog okay from Bainer from dogs and
we didn't know it at the time it was a
second dog that she had gotten the first
one she had to get back because the dog
was like aggressive or whatever okay
this dog Lucy Lucy apples you see that's
the name of the dog she got it bid her
kids and bit PK on the nose Atlanta
papers I'm like he had a gash he Ches
and ass he probably deserved so instead
of returning the dog for a second time I
guess she was like embarrassed or didn't
know whatever she found a home for it
like this lady here like she killed its
lady really wanted the dog like jury
thought she was giving it to like that's
nice family okay cut to like three days
later at least even everyone gets a call
from one of the shelters in LA like the
dog ended up in a kill shelter and lisas
pissed and to read like is so
embarrassed cuz like Kyle said it best
she's like if you get a reputation in
this town for being like someone who
like abuses animals like that doesn't go
away no and I do think jury could have
handled it way better like it was not
the right decision just to give it to
this random lady but like her heart was
in the right place she obviously if she
had known that it would end up in a
shelter like she would have done
something different what was its name
Lucy Lucy Lucy apple juicy I mean watch
the know so now it's like this all
happened off camera okay so essentially
I guess we could have like never known
about it but it was made a plot line
because they show up at Vanderpump dogs
to film one day and this guy John
blizzard who works for Lisa who Lisa
claims to not know but now there's like
pictures of him like literally at her
bar mitzva like they're best friends
like she's like I don't even know John
blaze ed and there's like a literary
million photos meant that's about 2015
he like brings it up and he's like you
know just this dog look familiar
and Teddy's like is that treats dog
no say your name is that Lucy Lucy apple
juicy and this is like John do not talk
about it seriously don't want to talk
about it so I was very confused because
it definitely seemed like it was a setup
to talk about it but then Lisa I was
like not wanting to talk about it so
they go to lunch and to eat and Lisa I
go to lunch and she goes to eat I want
you to know Teddy knows about the dog
she's best friends with John Blizzard
and Teddy's like I am NOT best times of
John Blizzard like I did a soul cycle
ride with John blizzard for Vanderpump
dogs like so the money could benefit
Vanderpump dogs like right that's what
in the extent of our relationship but
Lisa Vanderpump's really trying to make
it seem like Teddy found out in their
information because again there's
already a riff on you sure there's
already a rift between teddy and jury
and really at least as harping on that
so when Lisa Vanderpump starts to like
be weird
Teddy comes out full steam ahead she's
like are you [ __ ] kidding me like
it's like I will hold you guys know I
was a part of this plan me you and John
Blizzard had a plan to bring it up on
Vanderpump dogs when we're at and I was
all on board until you start saying no I
don't want to talk about it trying to
make it seem like I'm the only one who's
trying to she does this every single
season so at first it really looks bad
on Teddy's part because it's like you
should see text messages of Teddy being
like okay I'll bring it up at Vanderpump
dogs so Teddy looks really complicit and
Teddy owns her part she's like I'm not a
liar I like Teddy I hate to read I hated
to read and I wanted to be a part of
this plan to take her down but then Lisa
Vanderpump takes herself out of the
equation to try and pin it all on me and
I'm not [ __ ] down for that so I'm
coming with all the receipts so right
now it's not looking great for Teddy but
I've been reading her blogs which is and
I've been reading Lisa Vanderpump's
going I know okay hitting the blogs has
been so helpful there's so much more
than we know okay so what do you think
it from the blogs from the blogs
it's that Teddy is owning her part like
there was this huge plan and I took part
of it because like sarit was mean to me
at the Reunion or whatever they so
basically Lisa set the plan classic and
then took herself out of the equation to
make it look really bad for Teddy which
is what she always does Munchausen's
everybody hold the bag so now and now
that Teddy's like just not holding back
it's igniting a fire under Lisa Rinna
Erica Jane and Kyle who have all been
people who have like been apart or like
been a victim of these kind of schemes
and they're all coming for her so hard
like it's bad and they're telling the
truth of when they were in the same
position right so they were like Teddy
we believe you because I mean this is
the best day been there done his life
like whew so now it's
I mean there's no way that if I were at
least Vanderpump I would ever show up to
the reunion like she she she loses
benefits a lot of things but she did not
take accountability for actions like in
a friendship like there's giving tickets
like I [ __ ] up I'm sorry or you hurt
my feelings you should be sorry like you
have to be able and that's what a good
housewife is it's like you have to be in
the drama but then be able to own your
part yeah [ __ ] up and that's Lisa
Vanderpump's the biggest detriment is
that she can never own up to like the
smallest things her sorry so I'm sorry
you felt that way like if you even get
misinterpreted my email I'm sorry you
misinterpreted my British humor you know
like it's yeah [ __ ] so I think there's
no worse way to go out as a housewife
then not showing up to the reunion a la
Adrienne Maloof back in the day I don't
think there's any way just because if
Lisa Vanderpump shows up she'll have to
do the one thing she's incapable of and
that's owning up to her [ __ ] do you
think she's capable of doing it Tuesday
on her house is Beverly Hills no I don't
think she's gonna show up to the reunion
and I do think this is her last season
as a housewife what a way to go Lisa
but she's setting it up for there to be
I think a reality show what better from
dogs because now we're knowing me we
know who John Sesa and John Blizzard are
like why should I know them because they
have a show coming up and applesauce II
Wasi and Juicy Lucy alphab you see like
yes so that's what I think it's all this
like master manipulation do you think
that she set this up to get off no no
because in her in her perfect world this
is never how it would have ended you
know yeah I have a question for you
yeah about just the inner workings of
like the relationships and the dynamics
in Vanderpump rules because minerals
really is an amazing show besides for
the fact that Lisa Vanderpump is a part
of it like every time they feel mad sir
it's so stupid like I don't care you try
to tell me Katie's a waitress please she
gets paid five thousand dollars for an
Instagram post you know what I mean it's
so [ __ ] stupid I mean I actually
think Katie does have to go and say okay
you know I'm just saying but like her
income is not coming in my brain when
scheana and loll are like please said
can we get two days off it's like are
you kidding me it's so stupid
so it's ridiculous and now the tomtom of
it all has brought us like for a while
like we were moving away from Lisa R and
I'm like the show could have very well
exist without her but now at tomtom like
she's very much back in the middie or
groove now I want to ask and you might
not know the answer to this but it seems
really unfair that like Tom and Tom got
this restaurant when like Tom Schwartz
never really worked at Sur he wasn't
really an a character on the show and
like Jax who
like bled out for the show like his
blood sweat and tears went into
embarrassing himself in the show the
face of it all
the lauralee of it all the [ __ ]
Carmen of it all you know what I mean
like he's really been like the heart and
soul of the show and like he really has
been made out to look and he's not
reaping many of the rewards like Tom Tom
wears like Tom Schwartz like showed up
to pump one day had a panic attack about
to leave it's Jax like upset about it I
have no idea in regards to Jax but I
think this is my opinion I think that
Lisa adores Katie yeah I think she hates
Jax and I think she hates Jax and I
wouldn't be surprised if Katie
off-camera had gone to Lisa and been
like how can we give Schwartz ee-yeah
like a more in bonafide position on the
cast
yeah and that just made sense no totally
it just like seems [ __ ] up I know we
this housewife she is crazy no I know
so whose team are you on I'm firmly on
team jetting so it's like so it's it's a
temporary dance it steady against Lisa
it's everyone against Lisa pretty much
but I mean essentially no grammars being
so [ __ ] thirsty like trying
she's been now friend of housewife for
two seasons and like it's not enough for
her and she's like every time she gets a
modicum of screen time she just thirsts
out to the furthest possible extent and
she [ __ ] hates to read so she's being
on Team Lisa but she's just making me
hate her more oh my I don't think she's
gonna show up and I do think this is the
last time and a lot of people are like
you should be nicer to her like her
brother passed away like it's really sad
but like yes Eileen Davidson was on an
entire season and didn't tell anyone
that her mom died literally a day before
they started filming and Lisa Vanderpump
was so mean to her and took me sedan
from two seasons to come up to her and
be like I wanted to apologize like
literally like it wasn't until they were
at it was with Eaton Sassoon at the
season finale yeah it was wasn't until
that where she apologized for just being
so hard on Eileen when Eileen was going
through such a hard time and struggling
silently yeah so it's like you know what
I should feel bad for Lisa but I don't
what do you think Lisa could say that
could redeem her sorry
that's owned it in the words of Lisa
Rinna own it Lisa own it there's just
something like humbling about the house
right so it's like no matter how much
everyone loves you at some point you
[ __ ] up and you have to apologize yeah
and Lisa Vanderpump has never been put
in that position or she hasn't she said
somehow circumvented a that is my least
favorite quality and even being shamed
lack of self-awareness like like I'm
just knowing when
you're wrong like I am wrong [ __ ] die
all the time I am sorry all the time and
there's something like really grounding
about just like owning it yeah right she
can't do actually it feels I don't get
people who think that apologies like
make them weak no I couldn't agree more
it actually makes you look so like
relatable and strong that's why Bethany
drives me nuts because I don't think
she's good at taking accountability
better in the last couple see signs that
I agree with but I do often think she's
put in positions to take accountability
for things for like there's no
accountability that needs to be taken
like saying that she didn't thank
Dorinda enough for the Nutcracker I was
just gonna say like she could have
thanked her in two more for the
Nutcracker but are you kidding me first
of all did you see her she was literally
crying like was screaming at the top of
her lungs yes and apparently what
Bethenny said on watch outside she was
like Jordan didn't even get it for me
like I she gave me her guy and then like
I went back and forth I paid for it like
it was him and I on this thing where
it's like he just
jorinda gave her the contact I was she's
like here's the guy call right but still
and le's and she was very appreciative
in the berkshires or wherever they did
it like I'm sorry I see she they put her
in these positions like they hold her to
a higher standard that's true I'm also
just like a Bethenny apologist and I own
that like I would defend her to the
death I love her so much did you always
love Lisa before the season no I've
always known that Lisa Vanderpump was
the way that she was yep me too if you
can't be my friend and please don't be
my enemy like she was manipulating back
then at Aaron Armstrong I know it's I've
known from the very beginning but
there's yes that's really where it
started to unravel oh my god wait and
forget Ready's on this season how
[ __ ] dare De Palma started she had
brandy and then Sheena Sheena which like
brandy was her rider tied like a really
good friend friends with Kennan's like
you're gonna put her in a position Oh
with the lady who broke up your family
unreal unreal okay
speaking of unreal I don't know that's
Mike right from People magazine hmm
David Foster jokes that he'd be in jail
right now if his daughter had wanted to
go to college so basically a David
bought iron foster put up a screenshot
of a text that she got from her debt on
Instagram thank God you don't want to go
to college I'd be in jail right now oh
my god and you know and she kept kept in
it thanks for the confidence dad several
stars found the common funny including
including Nina Dobrev who wrote a cat
with three crying laughing emoji
spaces and selma blair who wrote really
is the best post lisa rinna meanwhile
simply commented david while katie
couric added your dad with the
sunglasses emoji as captured by
instagram so i thought it was funny when
i saw but i'm like damn people have
taken this thing so seriously i'm like i
now she's gonna get in trouble but she
did cuz like famous spawn can i get to
do whatever they want exactly but what
are your thoughts here on the on the
college admissions scandal i think it's
i would like to believe that I would not
do that for my children but I don't have
kids and I know how much I love my
girlfriend and I know how much I love
like my brother and my sister and like
my dog I would like [ __ ] I don't have
a dog but if I did I'd imagine but like
I would kill cheat and steal so like a
part of me feels like I kind of
understand it right I feel like society
has taken a moral high ground on them
like you're bad and it's like you are
bad what you did was wrong wrong you
took away a spot from a kid who really
worked hard and just didn't have the
access that you did and that's [ __ ] up
but I have a hard time believing that a
lot of people who if they were in that
position and had unlimited resources
money power like they wouldn't do the
same for their kids you know plus if
everybody in the communities doing it
which clearly they were right then it's
like normalized right it's like well so
and so down the street you're doing it
right and it's like Hollywood it's just
like pretentious bubble that you don't
even realize like something's [ __ ] up
until the rest of the world finds out
about it although Olivia Munn said it's
not about the love of their children
it's about them having like an elite
degree which I also agree with ya know
and that what Jackie said shocky been a
great point she's like okay so your kid
doesn't deserve to go to the school no
how are they gonna survive there not
that you're actually putting them and
you're doing them a disservice by
letting them think that they're great
and amazing and then like there they go
and they flop in there like why couldn't
I do it I would I was as good as
everyone else in any war you deserve to
be in that school you know I go back
it's wrong my little brother he went to
Harvard shut the [ __ ] up he's a wicked
smile the one that went to my show
yes there was a Harvard grad at my show
that is a first and now he's pre-med
shut the [ __ ] up I'll be single
ya know anymore I know Margo totally a
doctor a Harvard dive into some [ __ ]
about this show
she was a working girl back then also
him and I were wasted of chocolate okay
continue okay so he wrote so my dad
would Harvard so it's like legacy you to
Juba Donner I'm is certainly not where
you at a college a good college my
parents were furious at me I didn't know
you came from like a smart family I do
and my mama to BC and my sister would be
saved by just Botox right oh yes honey
he's gonna come to New York and do it
okay good you I'm changing all the show
Oh done I got my lips under I tell you
no can do you notice no which is a good
thing you know I did very little and now
when I go back I'm gonna need to do more
cuz like I'm hooked I'm really like it's
like change my life sorry continue I
keep it I want I actually want to do all
the stuff didn't you do something with
your chin of course yes I did the
natural neck lift what is that it's
basically uh outpatient liposuction for
your chin and not only that cuz like
anyone can do that but she patented this
great surgery and I only recommend dr.
Sherin easy to do it cuz it's her
surgery so anybody I have no scars she
went in through the bottoms of the lobes
in my ears and had like a little scab
there and then it went away it was crazy
I don't know how to hurt it like hell
but I was numbed and I was also just on
drugs and being way too dramatic I had
very low tolerance for me so don't take
wicked dramatic don't take like advice
for me but so not only do cheat like
stuff the chin out cuz when you look at
my double chin I was I need I'm like I
want this but what she also did was
remove fat from my gels so because you
don't realize that when you gain weight
and you get fat in your face the fat in
your jowls brings your whole face to
like kind of sag so because I was only
23 when I had the surgery right she
removed the fat from my jowls which kind
of lifted my face back up back to like
the elasticity like the way that it was
supposed to be so it was really just
like a great procedure
well it looks [ __ ] Fabian if you want
to intro for any work I love showing you
pretty much do I tell everyone like I
have literally recommended 1000 people
for that surgery I am so yeah and people
think that I'm like um being mean that
I'm like you need a surgery no I'm just
saying I don't want everyone to feel as
good that as I do you know what I mean
yeah they start you know please finish
us off so my brother he so my dad was
legacy so obviously that like it's a
connection it helps but it's not a
guarantee you get it right and my dad
like couldn't my dad at interviews for
Harvard but he couldn't interview his
own son and Mehmet ISM
so my brother wrote his essay
like went downstairs talk to the family
like like they went over it they like
gave notes bah bah and afterwards my
brother decided to go upstairs and
rewrite the essay from scratch because
he said that the fact that my parents
helped him meant that it wasn't a
hundred percent his oh my god he's and
so honorable
that is an Ivy League student well so I
would love to get your opinion on this
because now a lot of the discourse
around this
oh sorry those guys subject is like okay
so that's an illegal way of getting into
college but there are like more
considered moral ways like donating a
building or that's a thing as people do
do that as well and have for years right
it's kind of this gray area and also now
why you know legacy is considered like a
leg up because like it yep even though
like it necessarily doesn't mean it just
goes like your dad went to Harvard
doesn't mean you're smart you know what
I mean
but that's considered it's considered
like a leg up so now people say so
what's the difference between that and
you know doing it the more illegal way
right and well and here's a day like I
think that the girls should be all
expelled or all the kids oh you do Absa
well the Laughlin girls have decided not
to return on their own
well they the bullying alone believed
they weren't expelled yeah I mean us he
was just taking their sweet time making
a decision and they didn't want to wait
for the decision there alright nevermind
round so they should have expelled them
the parents should definitely be I don't
know find or something but going to jail
and having the FBI draw guns 6 a.m. yeah
it's a little extra well so then it
opens up a whole other conversation
where one of the toasters put me onto
this threat on Twitter that was like a
really upsetting and it was different
cases in which poor or black women were
did like similar things like they lied
about their district so there came to go
to the better school or like they were
homeless and they said they lived here
so the kid had get into the public
school and that district yeah and they
were literally sentenced to jail like
for like five or to 12 years now see in
that case I would say that let that go
right of course and it's like that's so
[ __ ] up and then most likely like Lori
Loughlin Felicity Huffman like won't do
time right just because of their
privilege like that's not fair i but
neither is the other situation i don't
think either of the women should go to
jail do you know what i mean i think
jail is way harsh time right for anyone
for anyone I think it's a slap on the
wrist and like a financial punishment
you know and then your kids get expelled
from the school so it's like what's the
point of even doing it cuz if they get
caught it's like your money
lost anyway right and so USC released a
statement being like we've become aware
like the US government has made it clear
that we are a victim in this we had no
idea like oh we are baby so much yeah I
would love to hear your thoughts on that
because when I read that I'm like that's
really low of you I've literally no
doubt in my mind that like someone in
admissions knew exactly what was going
on my conspiracy theory is is that the
FBI they don't just investigate things
for like the sake of it Felicity Huffman
right you know well and now it's coming
out the reason why they know all about
this is because one this guy whose
daughter went to Yale he was being
investigated completely separately on
like SEC like Wall Street [ __ ] and
he was like I have a great story for you
release my time give me immunity or some
[ __ ] and I'll tell you about this a ring
of celebrities rich people I all because
little rash yeah Oh crazy oh my god all
this one guy what a weasel I know that's
crazy
weasel season so I feel like though that
this is just the first year this is my
conspiracy theory I think the FBI went
in there making examples out of these
celebrities because they can and then I
think this second phase is gonna be
trying to figure out which schools are
actually culpable Blissett yeah and
complicit and which schools need to be
like then seriously find and punish and
that I'm here for ya but also like the
rejiggering of the system like women who
are sitting in prison right now like for
just trying to give their kids a better
life like are you kidding yeah like I
would this thread was so it was like
picture after picture of different moms
who were either homeless or just like
really out and they're literally sitting
in jail how crazy is that mail fraud
it's [ __ ] yeah and then it's like
that's why people are so incensed by
this because like most likely like
nothing's gonna happen really right in
terms of jail time like they'll have to
pay but like they're billionaires like
it's not a big it's not a problem for
them right it's just like it's so
corrupt and this is what Kim
Kardashian's out here trying to do
prison reform do you see the work that
Kim Kardashian's doing do you follow her
on Twitter girl I see what she's do I
love her like I really like every time
she like breathes I'm given more reason
to just out here like defend and stand
her I I can't when she was screaming and
her sisters in Japan over there outfit
was so funny I was so pissed
no I'm sorry it was so bad I'm talking
about this good story because it's so
funny and I absolutely love the subject
of this story and like
like I said I'm out here just did I use
the shows a platform to defend people
that I like that's literally yet
southern charm star chef bros zero charm
in getting tossed from a VIP tent
there's a video golf's a gentlemen's
game so it's no surprise southern Shep
starship southern Shep southern charm
stars Shep God has asked ejected from a
VIP tent when he started acting the fool
that's from TMZ I would never say that I
love it we're told Shep hit up the
Players Championship Friday at TPC
Sawgrass in Ponte Vedra Beach Florida
where he had an incredible view of the
17th hole from inside the type of
Fillion VIP tent witnesses at the event
tell us Shep drank a little too much
booze became belligerent and pestering
guests he also got up and started
dancing blocking people's view we're
told a woman working the event asked
Shep to leave but he refused
that's when st. Johns County sheriff's
deputies stepped in a spokesperson tell
us that the deputies working the event
escorted chef out of the tent out of the
tent by the way
TMZ writes in non-english I know out of
the tent they were an O you TTA
outa attempt without incident he was not
arrested and removed from the tent but
just not from the event lucky guy that
put his championship arguably has the
best class of golfers from top to bottom
so lots of great golf to watch I mean
this is so funny and honestly like golf
is so boring it's like you just want to
drink and party and dance like I'm with
chef I'm in the VIP tent like I'm like
throwing down listening to music and
everyone's own boring a coffe with like
their collared shirts like kicking about
I love Shep me too um I'm so not
surprised by the chef gets [ __ ]
wasted yeah wherever he go and that's
why he's a good time that's why he makes
for great television I know is he like
into any threat of any sort of like
immediate no he wasn't arrested they
just kicked him out of the tent he still
got to stay at the event but just like
not in this special bit tent which like
says hey question so you love Shep I
love Shep but would you ever let Shep
date somebody you love um to be honest
yeah really because I feel like what we
see on the show is really not him like
anytime we've hung out like me like very
deep meaningful conversations like about
books and I just like pretend to know
what books he's talking about which pas
yeah I don't know like Moby Dick or some
[ __ ] I mean oh you were gonna say that
no like every time I do I'm like I love
him like he's very charming very
charming southern charms yeah and I have
never seen him be like rude or
disrespectful to a woman but maybe anime
me that's just like an act that
plays on on on TV or that is who he is
but like I'm married and he respects me
I don't know right I like him I would
let him date someone I know
hi hottest [ __ ] he's so handsome he's a
little like Dobby yeah but like in a hot
like frat bro way yeah I mean he does
have Peter Pan syndrome
oh it's annoying like the lack of
ambition asses when you would you watch
other in charm um religiously do you
what are your thoughts on Craig
I feel like bad for him like when
different show first aired on the Craig
is hot like I want Craig yep
and rag is too skinny yeah which yeah I
great words those words never come out
of hahaha no such thing but he's just
like I mean and know me I hate that her
name is know me cuz its Naomi wait but
for whatever reason they call her know
me they do I mean she's been on the show
I Colin I Owen well Craig calls her know
me maybe he's just like weird whether
that but she's French so like how do
they pronounce that's what I'm wondering
if it's that but I love her
me too and so the fact that she's like
so sick of him says it all ya know and
he I feel like the show is great for him
but like his life would have turned out
so differently if he hadn't gotten on
the show do you know name Ian a better
way oh oh better is he gonna be back to
season he's like moved to the Bahamas or
some [ __ ] like he's always in the
Bahamas I have no idea
Wow yeah I just love this story I think
it's hilarious like that's actually
something that what happened to me cuz
like any time I met never totally and it
turns out to be like a snooze fest like
where's the bar hit the DJ the
dancefloor and I probably what chef was
just trying to do oh girl I feel like I
said I did that at your sister's wedding
accident wasn't a snooze fest no but
there was an amazing magical kingdom and
there was like tequila shots all around
so like you were just doing what you
were told
oh my god i harassed i harassed selena
gomez oh my god we that was so funny
okay so I only saw it the next morning
on your Instagram story but my
half-brother brought a date and she was
like this beautiful girl yep and she
really did look like Selena Gomez like
Taylor walks into the the party room
from cocktail hour and it's like
Instagram clearly I'm already wait she's
Instagram storing and like she gets of
my half-brothers date in the picture and
she's like filming and you could hear
her drunk voice I better I should say oh
my god you look way too leaning go man
so funny I let me meet screen recording
inside did to everyone I knew I just
thought it was so funny cuz hey she
really didn't look like Selena Gomez
would be it's just like that was like a
drug it's like whenever you're in a bath
time you just are going to be nice to
girls when you're beautiful it was so
funny oh my god did you hang out with
her no just that one kept on dancing -
oh my god it was so funny like I truly
was died it was honestly like Premium
[ __ ] content oh my god have you
enjoyed it
what are you watching on TV now oh you
better have bros on tonight were you
watching The Bachelor
you know what I'm not a bachelor person
and I feel like I have to be my mom and
dad watch it honestly just for like your
career like no like I hate it but a lot
of people literally tune into the show
my just get into it
a while ago and before like it was cool
and it was so good like there was a real
like Emily Maynard like she was a real
girl who lost her fiance like she just
wanted love now it's it used to be like
out of the 30 girls that started like
maybe one or two of them was really
there for the wrong reasons like to get
their own TV show yes now it's like out
of the 30 girls there's one or two there
who are like actually there if I love
and it's terrible I know and I really
don't feel like anything's real anymore
it's just such a time commitment yeah
and I don't know I mean my money's are
back I have you know I'm getting a
haircut tonight and I'm going to dinner
with those parents all in the time that
I would've been [ __ ] watching The
Bachelor say it's [ __ ]
why don't we do Saul like revolt and
refuse to watch it okay so I that and
nobody did it with me and every time
they announce to the bachelor or the
Bachelorette is there like we hate them
more revolting then everyone always
comes back to watching it and I feel
left out and I do think like for work
like it's just not wise of me not to
watch it because like people like rely
on the toast to recap and keep them in
tune
I know I know [ __ ] a fine I will jump
back on for bachelorettes yeah and it's
gonna be a weird season because she's
like camp a two words together it's very
odd really yeah what about bachelor in
paradise oh it's so good like good but
the annoying thing is that I haven't
watched for so many years no not only
that it's like the characters come off
this these past like two to three
seasons and it's like you want to know
them and let get to know them first and
so when you don't know anything about
them and they come I'm paradise it's
like you're missing something you know
yeah the knowledge so maybe I'll just
like go back and binge watch it there's
only what fifty seven [ __ ] thousand
episode watch like old season it's
actually really interesting I watched
one with like Andrew Firestone oh that's
like really old I know like Jesse Palmer
who does Daily Mail TV you know the host
of jelly yes he was the first bachelor
ever I actually auditioned with him and
my girlfriend was like are you scared
and I was like I don't know who he
additionally him for what he was doing
Daily Mail and I like auditioned to be
like a correspondent shut the [ __ ] up I
was bad stop you do a lot of like
hosting I try to do more psq tfq maybe
maybe not younger getting younger again
I'm really good at that
yeah thank you I actually just yesterday
unfollowed Nico Twitter all on Instagram
why just because it's like it's a lot
he's a lot he's he's very into like
myself the body yeah and I would say
like I liked it but um you know I'm
married right you know it's like it's a
little um tell me some tea aren't porn
I bet yes tell me some tea about the
younger crowd like what goes on behind
the scenes I don't know that there isn't
et they're all really [ __ ] nice
anyone not nice not like literally no
one's not nice I thought Hilary Duff
maybe wasn't nice right she wasn't nice
to me when I was a teenager in the
Bahamas and if you could you know send
the message because we really like yeah
like she traumatized me what was this
I've always been like celebrity obsessed
like the fact that they do this for a
living is not shocking like I've since
the quarry in the house days have really
just been obsessed and I mean my friends
went to the Bahamas Atlantis for spring
break of course and not when we were
like 16 we're in the casino like they
couldn't do anything so we were just
standing around and [ __ ]
that's where I met Andy Cohen for the
first time we have this picture it's so
good and this is when Atlantis was like
at its peak and then [ __ ] Hilary Duff
was there and like this was like right
after Lizzie McGuire Movie like we were
obsessed and we were just like staring
at her and she literally comes over to
me and I could be friends like we're
like wearing our wedges we're like tiny
she goes if I take a picture with you
will you stop staring and I love that
and you're like yeah I would take a
picture but like it made me feel so
uncomfortable and like really like and
now anytime anytime anyone has ever
asked me for a photo I'm like do not be
Hilary Duff do not be you know like I
was just like so scarred by it and it's
the worst to the state of worst
interaction I've ever had with a
celebrity
she so last what was it the first
episode you tell us I said that please
no
so the first episode of last season it
was the entire cast and Hillary bailed
out super last minute and I was like
she's pregnant she was prank okay
exactly
so when it came around for the season
finale cuz she was out in California she
flew out for it and when she came she
was like I'm so sorry that I was here I
was so pregnant she said I felt like if
I put one more pair of Spanx I would
like literally smushy to death I feel
like when that happened to me she was
definitely in her 20s and just like a
[ __ ] like paparazzi like Lindsay Lohan
babe total and now she's like been
grounded by the fact that like she's a
mom and like has a successful career
behind her like also I love her
Instagram when she that calls out
paparazzi yeah I really like her but
like I'll never be able to forget that
one heart is it crazy cuz think about I
mean it can have such an impact on you
like you're also in a position now we're
like you could give somebody that day
too and why sure I need you know I would
never say that well that's that's true
that that that would that would take
essence that's the very least like I'm
only just like some if it ever goes
badly if someone s our picture it's just
like I'm tired and I'm not like people
expect me to like dance through me dad
see though it's like you're funny you
make a joke like and I'm just like hey
how are you you know like I might be
just like a letdown in person have you
ever had somebody like shade you in
person one time and not in person
I was in San where the [ __ ] was I you
travel the world no I really don't where
the [ __ ] whatever Diego San Antonio San
Juan
oh no honestly I have no idea ever this
guy stand something I may be San
Francisco okay and it was the opening of
spin near the ping pong place in the
city they new location to me a man
hosted it there and I ran a contest on
my Instagram like three girls to win and
the winners were contacted eight to ten
crumbs show up I had like a table and
everything and I was hanging out with
the winners and I actually stayed longer
I wouldn't stay from eight to ten I was
like having such a good time right and
at 10:30 one of the girls shows up and I
left at 11:00 an hour after I was
supposed to leave and I was like take
the table
I learned him french fries bottles I'm
like go have fun and she sent me the
nastiest message like I got a blow-up
who you're such a disappointment you're
entitled [ __ ] I'm like [ __ ] you went
30 minutes late now I was still [ __ ]
there are you kidding me on you should
beat me feels so bad that's like the
worst match message to get like that
like when somebody meets you like you're
like you let them down and like I really
have to try super hearts like always be
like this
in person yes and but it's really hard
to always maintain you know and it's
like are you kidding me like you were 30
minutes late the event was technically
over for late literally the fact you
were still there was kind of like so
what's fun it was ping pong and there
was like a ping pong competition that me
and Ben play doubles against like actual
- like Olympic ping pong or you guys win
of course not I couldn't even get the
ball over the table it was a great event
like she just like put a terrible taste
in my mouth oh I was energy when I sing
you know the world girl you lookyou it
you look here with your white boots
face you like this outfit I do well
you'll be seeing you luxe is my brand
new it's my uniform I have four of these
oh do you what colors just this oh for
the same color uh-huh you cute I like a
white boot I feel like I'm sweating
profusely through my dress I'm always
sweating oh my god and I feel like like
for shoot like shoes for like this time
of year or super hard because it's like
winter but it's like not I know you know
those are cute thank you I've been like
really into it now that I have this like
new shoe wall in my apartment
rest in peace rest in peace Karl
obviously about this because now it's
that he died like the price went down
actually trust percentage me for free
now then have these like to new like
glamorous shoe walls in my closet it has
like I just buy shoes for like the sake
of having them in my closet you know any
mean um I remember when I had my
apartment Rebecca I did the same thing
yeah I have to fill in my closet right
so I mean now I'm like I got again a
when I sew em Jamie is a sponsor of the
toast and they like they like pick out a
pair I'm like can I get six like just
like I have a sushi well they're like no
but they're actually really cute and I
got um boots and Jackie got sneakers and
Jackie Larry work with sneakers to the
bone like they got a hole in the bottom
and she had to ask for another pair
we're just like so thirsty with all of
our sponsors like can we have more free
product but em Jimmy is actually and now
I just saw that they're selling them at
Bloomingdale's and I'm like damn the
toast is really making these brands pop
off and Jimmy is basically the same
quality like leather shoes that like
Gucci like and
all the like high Italian luxury brands
make but it's like at a normal price so
it's like huh
yeah it's this is their logo ready-made
the old way sold the new way I like it
yes so here we obviously have a code for
you because like what is this show
without codes go see for yourself how
amazing these shoes are at em Jimmy calm
slash toast for $50 off your first pair
that's letters mg EMI dot-com slash
toast for $50 off your first pair MJ
me.com slash toast
MJ me Italian luxury made the old way
sold the new way I have so enjoyed
hanging out with you is there anything
else you want to talk about like you
know life update so you want to share
with the group I don't think so
you're just like killing it I'm just
how's the show so by the way for those
who aren't maybe new toasters chose
trekkers a longtime friend of the toast
but is an OG radio host you weren't
serious for 11 years
yeah 11 12 ish 7 I'm crazy I know crazy
and now you do your own radio show
Monday through Friday at three hours to
to get re now that still that can fun
get along it's so long oh my god I
co-hosted with you once when you were
doing your three-hour show I used to be
a guest like 10 minutes right and then
you need a coast and you were like one
day 7:00 a.m. to 10 a.m. and I was like
this [ __ ] I got there like 6:30 I was
like trying to set up this [ __ ] rolls
in at 6:59 ready it was the hardest
longest day of my life
right it's like soul-crushing just
sucking so now you do what 8 to 10 8 10
much better yep Monday through Friday
it's live you can call in it's called
the Taylor strucker show and you can
subscribe at Taylor's trekker calm and
then also my podcast
taste taste of Taylor which is like a
little taste of Taylor you've got a girl
like that name thank you like a little
picture on it it's like taste it's taste
of Taylor which is me and then some porn
star named Taylor shut the [ __ ] up where
I choose one called taste of Taylor yeah
I mean you just did an episode with
Jackie that people like raved about I
haven't listened to it yet but Jimbo
loved it no turkey ashtray oh yes yeah
Jason Taylor yes what did you guys talk
about we talked you talked [ __ ] about me
total we were we were actually gonna
talk a little bit about the wedding and
then we got totally off course and we
just talked about like the industry and
I had no idea how she got involved in
this business and I had no idea how you
guys even like wanted to start doing the
morning toast Shia shook she really is
like has we
even though she only worked in like a
corporate setting for like three or four
years yeah where she is like uh with
what is it wealth of knowledge she has a
wealth of knowledge
well wise beyond her years that's why
she's like really like the the HR
compliance businesswoman of this show
like I'm just like the outlier like you
know problem child's I love her well
she's at Jerry duty right now but I know
watching I wonder if she's bored told
her have you ever do you serve jury duty
in Boston or here um here torture I had
to serve right before my wedding I wish
I'd served through my wedding so I
didn't get married lol my friend Jenna
had jury duty with Donald Trump like
[ __ ] before he yelled and he was
just like a New York resident like
businessman and he was like thinking
about running for president she and she
actually sent me a picture actually
should ask her for it he was the
craziest it and she said he was like
shaking hands with everyone no crazy is
that can you believe he's our president
Taylor Swift does jury duty I mean yeah
everyone does I mean she skipped out on
the Grammys to go to jury duty but that
was like right after the con anything
happened and I'm sure she could have
gotten out of it Joby's can get out of
it I think that they can find ways to
get out of it but I think eventually we
all must serve our civic duty I know
it's [ __ ]
I came up with an idea what they should
just like have a jury like in every
County like twelve people who it's like
there are full-time jobs and like you
train them to be unbiased agree you
train them to be like not bias you train
them to like look for whatever like
these people who are it's like their
professional job is to be like unbiased
jurors yes
instead of like wait like I just want to
say like I would be a terrible juror
like IPI self what the person is wearing
I could decide if they're guilty or not
[Laughter]
yes I think it's brilliant I cut you off
you were gonna say something I'm at
Taylor Swift I never like understood the
love of her that you had and then I
watched the reputation World Tour oh my
god you know it's so funny it's like out
of all the things she's done like
reputation world tours like the least
impressive for me really yeah like you
should really watch journey to fearless
I was sore
speaking out world tour I I'll give you
a list of things okay okay well everyone
thanks Taylor for filling in for Jackie
while she's being the rural juror
we are back tomorrow with Brian Kelly
co-host a who is the points guy we're
gonna do like a whole credit card themed
like points like advice segment like
base
the people just right in there like hey
I have this much debt and like I need
this like and he like figures is out for
them he's a he's a genius
and he also just like took me on a
private jets like I love um yeah I won't
talk about that and you were on a
private jet - yeah where did you go I
went from New York to LA oh that's a
great flight uh-huh and who do you find
a van nuys or LAX Van Nuys and whose
plane was it I can't say will you tell
me after because I won't get invited on
guess I'll tell you out there that's
what I was saying it's like I've been on
private jets many a time but never like
take a picture or like thirst out or
like making a big deal because it always
belongs to some rich person and like I
want to be like that thirsty loser it's
a scope I'm the t PG plane was just me
Margaret II BG and like we were all
thirsty
what was that plane we just charted it
oh and by we I mean hey thank you guys
so much for being here the morning shows
streamed live Monday through Friday
10:30 a.m. Eastern Time on YouTube and
them are also available as a podcast
pretty much anywhere you can find
podcasts at the morning toast I'm
Claudia a shy girl no job feel free to
follow Taylor's trekker on Instagram at
Taylor's trekker and the Taylor's
trekker show at checker calm yep oh wow
I got that right I wasn't expecting to
you impressed we will see you guys
tomorrow have an amazing blessed day
you